SPEAKER: Observability
is increasingly
required of our systems as we
work to improve reliability.
Metrics represent the health
of your system over time
and are a crucial
component of observability.
And while services running in
GCP benefit from out-of-the-box
platform instrumentation, it's
often necessary to add more.
Today, we'll take a look at
how to do that with OpenCensus
and Stackdriver.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Last time, we looked at how
our microservices can benefit
from a service mesh that
exports monitoring, logging,
and tracing data to Stackdriver.
Now, let's add our own
telemetry with custom metrics.
When considering adding
metric instrumentation
to your applications,
you generally
have three options
to choose from.
Your first option is to use
the Stackdriver Monitoring
API to send metrics and data
points to Stackdriver directly.
This is what the Stackdriver
monitoring agent does.
However, you should
know that this API
is low level and proprietary.
And at this point, we rarely
recommend using it directly.
Let's look at some
more extensible
and easier-to-use options.
Your second option
is to use Prometheus.
It's an open source
monitoring solution.
Because using
Prometheus involves
more than just
instrument and your code,
we'll come back to this
in our next episode.
Your third option and
the one we recommend
for creating your own custom
metric instrumentation
is OpenCensus.
It's a single
distribution of libraries
that collect metrics
and distributed traces
from your services.
Let's look at how
to use it to create
custom metrics and Stackdriver.
We'll use Node.js
for this example.
First, we need to install
the two required packages--
OpenCensus itself and
the Stackdriver Explorer.
We'll do that by
installing the packages
with NPM install
at the command line
or include them as part
of the Docker file.
Next, we'll include these
packages in our code.
This needs to be done at
the very top of the file
before any other code.
We are now ready to
start creating metrics.
But let's review the basic
concepts of the OpenCensus data
model first.
To start, we'll need a view.
It'll describe how to
collect and aggregate
individual measurements.
Views can be thought of
as the time series we'll
be adding points to later.
Next, we'll use measures
to describe how the data
points will be recorded.
We'll also specify
an aggregation,
which is a function
to summarize the data.
Finally, we'll
create measurements.
These will be our
actual data points.
We'll need to use the view
we created to aggregate them.
Otherwise, it'll get
dropped on ingest.
Now that we've covered
the data model,
let's walk through
the code we'll
need to write to actually
create and send metrics.
We'll put a link to the
repo and my actual code
and a detailed solution paper
in the video description.
First, we'll define
our export interval
and create the measure.
This is where we define
the metric that we'll
be sending the Stackdriver.
The key things here
are the fact that it's
going to be an Int64 value and
the name of the description
of the metric.
Next, we'll use that
definition to actually register
the metric with Stackdriver.
We're calling to
create new method
to create the view and then
the register view method
to actually register it.
Note that I'm using the
last value aggregation type.
This means that
only the last value
that was captured during the
export interval will be sent.
You can also use distribution
count and some aggregations.
After that, we'll register
the Stackdriver exporter.
This is the mechanism
that will send
the metrics to the Stackdriver
monitoring backend.
Finally, we are ready to
create actual data points.
We do that by referring to
the measure we already created
and specifying a value.
We are finally ready
to run our code
and send the metric
data to the Stackdriver.
And there it is.
I can see the metric
in Metrics Explorer.
It has the name I assigned it.
And it's showing the
last value that was
generated when I ran the code.
This can be an easy way to
expose additional information
about the performance and
health of your application
to Stackdriver
thanks to OpenCensus.
Thank you for joining
me today and come back
next time when we look at
another approach to custom
metrics with Prometheus.
That's it for this episode.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]